Jadi apa itu Qiskit?
Qiskit adalah kit pembangunan perisian sumber terbuka
untuk bekerja dengan komputer kuantum
pada peringkat circuit
algoritma dan modul aplikasi. SDK ini
membolehkan sesiapa sahaja mengaturcara komputer kuantum sebenar dari
laptop mereka. Dengan dua baris kod sahaja, kamu boleh akses
pelbagai sistem kuantum, bermula dari superkonduktor
hingga qubit ion terperangkap. Nak emulasikan gelagat komputer kuantum?
Tukar satu baris kod je
dan simulasikan circuit kuantum kamu dengan simulator berprestasi tinggi
kami. Qiskit adalah alat yang digunakan oleh puluhan
ribu orang di seluruh dunia yang cuba
membina masa depan. Sama ada kamu seorang penyelidik, pembangun,
atau baru nak mula,
Qiskit ada pelbagai
ciri untuk keperluan kamu,
yang membolehkan sesiapa sahaja buat benda-benda
seperti membina circuit kuantum pertama kamu,
menjalankan algoritma kuantum merentas domain,
dan mengkaji fenomena kuantum asas.
Mungkin sekarang masa yang sesuai untuk kamu terlibat sendiri
dan jumpa semua alat yang kamu perlukan,
termasuk mesin kuantum sebenar
dan SDK melalui Qiskit,
serta komuniti yang sedia mengalu-alukan kamu
dan menjawab sebarang soalan yang kamu ada sepanjang perjalanan ini.
Kamu boleh mula hari ini
di Qiskit.